alors comment ça va lui et ses turbines
vous étiez là oui j'étais là je n'ai pas
entendu je nous ai pas entendu
excusez-moi 200 femmes gémissent irina
alors on va parler politique qu'elle
partait dans une news outil politique
pour lutter contre la fraude la fraude
sociale estimé à plus de 14 milliards
d'euros en 2009 vers chez nord
la caisse nationale d'allocations
familiales a décidé d'engager des
experts en matière de fronde pour
effectuer des contrôles drastiques voici
la liste des prétendants pour ces postes
à pourvoir
tout de suite les prétendants lui c'est
jérôme 68 en sa qualité
un regard qui ne ment pas sur robbie la
comptabilité en suisse lui c'est patrick
il a 72 ans sa pièce de théâtre préféré
le malade imaginaire
son hobby il est moquée dans la rue avec
un pull sur les épaules
et lui c'est carlos 66 ans il adore les
renault safrane turbo diesel sur kobe la
magie il peut disparaître dans une
petite boîte
[Musique]
lui c'est dominique il a 71 ans et il
vient juste voir s'il ya des me
[Applaudissements]
on continue avec de l'écologie on
continue avec de l'écologie je vous en
supplie si je vous en supplie quoi je
vous en supplie cyril hanouna de quoi
que j'aime beaucoup
merci je t'aime bien tenté un autre il
ya quelques jours le conseil d'état
annoncé l'interdiction de la chasse à la
tourterelle des bois non à mercy bay
vidéo on peut dire que les on peut dire
que les carottes sont cuites pour les
chasseurs et 6 et on peut maintenant
c'est la bonne nouvelle on peut revoir
ses jolies volatile sur le littoral et
c'est tant mieux
moi je suis très contente que des
retours des oiseaux parce que les
oiseaux c'est des êtres humains comme
les autres
[Musique]
voilà
bon c'est pas c'est de lui sans lui
c'est un truc que j'avais piqué mon
beau-frère et même moi je ne voulais pas
d'amis via les glaces
oui mais il ya un rat prendre une glace
à la maison sympathique si on continue
avec l'international le président donald
trump s'est attiré les foudres en
minimisant une nouvelle fois le problème
du réchauffement climatique en déclarant
les accents sais pas je confirme oui je
confirme je suis plus glace oui que je
vois ça des propos qui ont vivement fait
réagir les militants écologistes
chanter exactement va continuer de la
santé en taisant telle épée guinot ces
projets coûtent qu est ce qu il a dit
qu'est ce que tu as dit des mots sont
bousculés j'ai l'impression d'avoir
avalé un accident de bagnols quoi aucune
idée santé depuis la fin du confinement
est la distante et les greens au tir
[Applaudissements]
jallet après qu'elle l'apprenne santé
santé santé quoi sauter les bino depuis
la fin du confinement
les files d'attentes wall e filles les
filles devant les laboratoires gêne
si vous n'aimez pas la variété dans des
soutes et par les autres les
laboratoires qui effectuent des
dépistages du comité 19 sont de plus en
plus grande
une idée de ce que je viens de dire est
compris cette phrase ne prenez pas la
route
en témoignent ces images prises lors
d'une ouverture de nous laboratoire ce
matin mais écoutez vous poussez vous la
totalité en berne heurter la tête à tête
et nausées
oui donc on a fait tout ça pour ça moi
je me demande si c'était pas même mieux
savoir faire les filles au défi santé
les greens haute pour ça pour ça qu'on
l'a fait c'est bon ça santé les greens
on l'a fait pour ça une étude sport
sport
on connaissait bleus et sport on
connaissait le tennisman de benoît pain
unis de père benoît paire d'actes
manqués laisser benoît paire le
tennisman lyon connaissait un peu moins
benoît paire le chanteur de musique
urbaine style en grosses exclues
découvrez son nouvel ep aller chez
kessal et ruia
[Musique]
c'est n'importe quoi mais là c'est la
convention entre vous avez raison c'est
un revers de petits sauvages
j'ai regardé vers de plus hauts je pète
les plombs super sympathique
6 la paire dont lubac blais roland
garros benoît bien sûr tu le sais tu
peux venir à la maison avec plaisir
surtout que je rappelle que tu me dois
500 ou ça fait maintenant trois ans
voilà neuf un pari il a joué de la main
gauche et moi de la main droite il
masque les estimé c'est tout bon ce soir
si tu veux pas rester ici l'argument je
veux c'est vrai tu peux nous ramener des
triangles vers 6 heures perdues je ne
préfère pas très chanceux
[Applaudissements]